welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i've been accused of hating star trek
enterprise because i've made one or two
comments about the show and how i feel
about it
but in this video i'm going to talk
about why i'm not a huge fan of the of
the whole series and more importantly
why i'm not angry at the show i'm just
disappointed
so in this video i'm going to talk about
some of the key episodes and i'm going
to talk about really you know why is i
was so disappointed with it but i'm also
going to tell you the things that i
really loved about the show this is not
going to be a hate video so first of all
let's just talk about how the series
kicked off
the casting
i was so excited when scott pakula was
announced as the captain for the next
show because i just thought that was
perfect casting and he was brilliant as
captain archer there are continuing
rumors that he is going to reappear in
some star trek franchise maybe stranger
worlds maybe um even discovery because
you know that show bounces around the
timeline like crazy
and i think those rumors
oh god i hope those are true because i
would love to see captain archer return
there are a few problems
with the enterprise series that we're
going to discuss in the next few minutes
that i think could be fixed and i wonder
if are going to be fixed by the
discovery series so why was the show
cancelled when it was
so let's discuss the ratings for a
second
when this aired on upn in the united
states enterprise was their biggest hit
by a mile the ratings were really really
good
but over the first series they dipped
and they continued to decline into the
second series when the third series
aired and manicotto took over the reigns
of show leader
the ratings did improve they really
beefed up the action in the series and
they created the zindy they decided to
go with one overarching storyline for
the entire series and it seemed to work
ratings improved so the setup those
first two episodes really set up the
whole series i've really chosen to talk
about broken bow not just because it was
the first episode because it's a couple
of those episodes that i'm going to
discuss in this video that i think
explain the whole problem with
enterprise how can you not love any
episode that has a decontamination sour
sequence with power in that
see the setup the enterprise isn't quite
ready
the vulcans are acting like
overprotective parents stopping their
kids from spreading their wings and
starfleet is itching to get out there
and get started it is that battle
between logic and emotion that actually
is a completely logical storyline and
completely makes sense it's a century
after jeffrey cochran made first contact
and
nothing and humanity really doesn't feel
like even though they've achieved loads
they wanted to achieve more that really
is really a defining character of
humanity they were always itching to go
that next step that next step that next
step
and the vulcans were desperately trying
to protect us i love that and it carries
on through the entire first series that
whole overarching storyline of us versus
the vulcans in that
love irritation relationship
and it's a storyline that i absolutely
adored
a storyline i don't adore and i'm going
to talk about more later
is the temporal cold war i actually
think this whole overarching first
episode of broken bow could have been
rewritten without changing the story
massively and taking the suliban and the
temporal cold war completely out of it
i actually think if they had have done
that and tweaked the storyline it would
have made for a better opening double
episode a more focused opening for the
series the technology and enterprise
this is set a hundred years before the
original series and i think they really
put a lot of effort into making sure
that the technology sat between
first contact and the original series
really really well
something they didn't bother with so
much of discovery they actually made the
discovery this incredibly advanced
starship that didn't really fit within
the timeline particularly well
but with enterprise it did
the ship wasn't quite ready their little
problems with the uh travelling warp
that the the um initial dampeners
couldn't quite keep up
they you know the weapons weren't good
enough sort of thing the the
transporters they had them but they
didn't trust them they didn't like them
i love that little bit at the end of
broken bow where and they have to do
they have to actually transport archer
and he's they're going oh chris is
everything still there change the names
for certain the weapon systems because
they weren't quite
there yet we don't see a photon torpedo
until much later in the series that sort
of thing
um i love how in those i think it's the
fourth or fifth episode something like
that they actually create the red alert
and these these protocols that they're
getting out there and having to sort of
learn how to be starfleet on the job
and i think they did that
really really well the next couple
episodes that i think really defined
this series and gave me a problem with
stormfront
and again this is a perfect example of
my love almost hate relationship with
the series they have characters like
vosk
who is a brilliant bad guy the makeup
was really good the actor they had for
it was really genuinely intense
this is a really good character that i'd
love to see a lot more of it was kind of
scary
but we only seen for this double episode
we only see the species for the double
episode
and then it turns out that they're the
ones that actually started the temporal
cold war in the first place and agent
daniels sent the enterprise back
to stop them
why didn't they just do that from the
beginning
it seems to me that agent daniels knew
this is where the cold war started
so why not just sort out from the
beginning
but
let's move that to one side for a second
the couple of things i really hate about
this episode and i and i genuinely do
hate this
alien says that's is i have a problem
with that it made the episode look
stupid from
straight away the whole premise this
there seems to be a thing with the
history channel
on um on discovery that everybody loves
aliens sharks and
the nazis and that's all we get alien
shark snatches alien shark snatches
now this episode seems to be trying to
put those together except they forgot
about the sharks um if there had been
sharks in this video history channel
lovers were [ __ ] loved it
but
it's been done to death
alienates his alienates it's been done
before it's been done in star trek
before i didn't need to see it
it i just wish they'd done that a
different way but actually then i watch
the episodes and it's done brilliantly
the whole thing with the new york being
under occupation and how new yorkers
reacted to that and something it's
really well written really well acted
and really well put together but the
immediate premise was stupid and i just
wish they'd tweaked it a little bit but
it's again it's a thing with enterprise
all the way through
they make these fundamental errors but
then they do the episodes really really
well
and that's frustrating as hell at the
end of stormfront as well i think they
missed a really golden opportunity the
enterprise reappears at earth and all
the other ships come to see them and to
welcome them back so i think but the
enterprise is very happily damaged now
they do upgrade and repair the vessel
for the start of the next episode manny
koto has talked since about how they
planned this big upgrade for the
enterprise at the start of series 5. why
didn't they do it to the start of series
four the enterprise comes back to earth
very heavily damaged that is a perfect
opportunity also at the end of the zindy
conflict is a complete
turnaround and a redirection for the
whole series they stopped calling it
just enterprise they started calling it
star trek enterprise there's definitely
a shift in what they planned for the
show
that would have been a perfect
opportunity to show that changing plan
by completely changing the enterprise
the plan was to create this whole body
section so that it looked a lot more
like a constitutional class but still
not quite so steadily another step in
between again we're talking about
they really missed a golden opportunity
to do that at this point
that's again frustrating knowing what
they wanted to do with the fifth series
i know they could have done it here
let's talk about a couple of episodes
that i absolutely adore
regenerations is not just one of my
favorite enterprise episodes it's one of
my star trek favorite episodes full stop
when this episode came on i absolutely
loved it obviously if you're watching
this video you'd have seen this episode
but i love how they linked it to the
movie first contact
the borg from the sphere were found
brought by the ship
the whole threat thing i actually wish
they'd kind of made that a double
episode regenerations and really pushed
it a little bit further
another double episode i absolutely
adored and wish they'd maybe gone a bit
further with was in a mirror darkly so
the double episode in series four where
we see
the mirror universe we found out from
manikoto later that actually there was a
plan
for enterprise to have virtually an
entire series maybe series five major
six
set in the mirror universe now this is
what those things are saying about how
discoveries kind of tried to fix some of
these mistakes
they've actually done that they had half
a series um set in the mirror universe
um i've always wondered if emperor's
show is supposed to be related to
empress hoshi is it supposed to be like
a great great granddaughter not sure
this episode is absolutely phenomenal i
love the overacting everybody in this
episode is helen rickman i just love
that um cancel christmas all the way
through this episode it's absolutely
overly acted hammed up
beautifully done and on purpose for a
reason though um
another thing i love about this episode
is that they're all showing their belly
buttons
no reason the women all show on the
belly buttons
um this this series is not exactly woke
i hate that phrase but it's not exactly
woke
um the only thing missing from the
series was really another shower scene
that would have been great she was so
cold the main thing i loved how they
brought the foliage back we see the
tholi and trappings that's how the
enterprise gets destroyed um i love that
we see the uss defiant a little nod to
the defiant there um i just love
everything about this episode i love the
sadistic doctor flocks oh my god his
character was so good i kind of wish
they dragged him back into the original
series because he was more interested in
the
normal doctor flocks really before i
speak about these are the voyages the
final episode the very contentious
marmite episode that um really divides
fans i just want to talk about canon i'm
not a huge fan of prequels if you're
going to do a prequel you've really got
to know what you're doing there has to
be a point to it this really comes down
to the number of why i'm not a huge fan
of enterprise
it's because
it's not what i thought it was going to
be
i thought it was going to be a series
telling us how the federation came to be
i would have thought that would make
sense
but
that's not really what the series was
about the series was really about the
temporal cold war and humanity going out
into space for the first time
i don't think they needed
the whole temporal cold war for a couple
of reasons
i actually don't think it brought a
great deal to the series i think the
whole thing with the zindy could have
been done without the temporal cold war
element to it and the sphere builders
um i think they could have still done
that series with a bit of re-tweaking
humanity is going out there and stepping
on people's toes pissed off the zindy
and and that's what triggered that
conflict this indy seemed to be quite an
important species but it'd been never
mentioned in star trek before we've
never seen that
the whole thing with the zindy come and
carve a massive big line right the east
coast of america
never mentioned before in star trek
canon is completely being messed with
think about the zindy and the whole of
series three
take out the zindy
and replace them with the romulans
we know there was a big formula in
conflict somewhere in this time period
before the federation or as part of why
the federation came to be removed zindy
replaced romulans that series all of a
sudden makes a lot more sense and i
think star trek fans would have been
more excited by it so that takes us into
the final episode these the voyages now
this is an episode i really really enjoy
and again manny cotto actually said this
was always going to be the final episode
of series four it was always planned
i actually think there's a little bit of
bs there i think this probably was
planned but i think it was rewritten
once they realized they were getting
cancelled they tried to shoehorn this
show to make it the final episode and to
round everything off best they could
i think this was supposed to be a teaser
for the next three series where they
were really going to start getting their
teeth stuck into how the federation came
to be or at very least how this initial
alliance that then became the federation
they keep making references to the past
six years that have just gone by that
that we don't get to see because we were
supposed to see it
so what i actually think of this show
as a final episode of the series
it's awful
it's really frustrating it tags back to
the enterprise tng series
unnecessarily
and as a final episode to the series
um it's almost like
in dallas when it turns out that that
one character was in the shower having a
dream because they wanted to bring him
back because he was so popular it was
all a dream
it's kind of like that sort of feel to
it it's like it's a it's a holographic
representation of what happened and it's
frustrating as hell but as an end of
series 4 episode teaser for series 5
with a little bit of rewriting this
would have been a really popular episode
um and that's again one of the reasons
why enterprise so frustrates me i don't
hate it it's just disappointing and
maddening at times this is a big problem
with the show it never really found its
identity
it never really seemed to know what it
was
was this
a series about the temporal cold war
was it a series about humanity going out
into space and into interstellar space
for the first time or was it about the
creation of starfleet and the beginnings
of the federation
it sort of jumped between those three
things
constantly
and never really found its own footing
d space nine had an identity really
early on voyager had an identity really
early on about wanting to get home but
wandering off as much as humanly
possible because they were still
federation i suppose there's still
starfleet they had to explore just go
home you idiots enterprise never had
that
star trek the next generation had its
identity really early on it had a simple
premise
starship explore
that you can go wherever you want with
that series
enterprise should have just done that
they should have just said
new ship
new interstellar space humanity taking
its first steps towards the federation
and that alliance
and then actually are seeing the the
first few steps towards the federation
if you remove the sulaban
and the temple cold war
completely from this series
i think you've got a much better show
but
we got what we got and we did get some
great star trek episodes from the series
and it was again i could say beautifully
made
so that's it that's why i don't hate
star trek enterprise i was just
disappointed by it
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification you really help us out and
go and join us on facebook it's the
sidetrack channel you can search for
just scitrek or there is a link in the
description thanks very much guys and uh
leave a comment tell me what you thought
about star trek enterprise
see you next time
[Music]
you